[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 31 mai voici les
titres
de la philosophie dès le plus jeune âge
à l'école élémentaire marcel pagnol de
coignières les élèves de cm2 ils sont
initiés ils suivent des cours à douze
reprises dans l'année un partenariat
entre l'éducation nationale et la
municipalité pour développer l'esprit
critique de ses enfants les élections
législatives approchent premier tour le
12 juin prochain 130 candidats sont en
course dans les yvelines dont une
majorité issus de petits partis khalid
et porte-t-il pourquoi sont ils autant
en lisant ce scrutin éléments de réponse
et puis alors que le tournoi de roland
garros bat son plein porte d'auteuil à
paris nous prendrons les nouvelles du
tennis yvelinois comment se porte-t-il
après deux années de crise sanitaire qui
sont les pépites à suivre lors moreau et
jean françois mettait du comité de
tennis des yvelines sont nos invités
mais avant de développer ses titres jean
luc mélenchon ce mardi soir à trappes le
leader de la france insoumise est
attendu devant le collège
gustave-courbet pour échanger soutenir
les parents d'élèves et professeurs des
collèges trappistes il sera aux côtés de
william martin est candidat nuxe de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale dans la 11e circonscription des
yvelines un déplacement en pleine
campagne des élections législatives
premier tour le 12 juin prochain et dans
une ville qui avaient largement voté
pour lui au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle à plus de 60% le maire à
dirab est également parmi ses soutiens
trappe l'une des douze communes choisies
par jean luc mélenchon vous l'avez vue
sur ces images un tour son meeting en
hologramme c'était le 5 avril dernier et
pour ces législatives 130 candidats en
tout sont en lice dans l'es12
circonscription des yvelines un scrutin
qui réunit beaucoup de candidats à
chaque fois et on en parle avec justin
brasier bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78
alors justin quels sont les enjeux pour
ces partis et notamment pour les petites
formations politiques en lice il faut
savoir déjà grégory que les élections
législatives c'est le rendent vous à ne
pas manquer pour les partis politiques
qu'ils soient établis en france où
qu'ils soient comme vous l'avez dit des
petits partis pourquoi et bien déjà il
ya deux enjeux de taille d'abord faire
passer des messages être candidat à une
élection ça donne de la visibilité et un
temps de parole et pour ces élections
légistatives contrairement aux
présidentielles il n'ya pas le barrage
déjà des 500 signatures donc chacun peut
se présenter
ça permet de faire passer les messages
tu as fait et ça c'est là nos objectifs
je vous rappelle que 69% des électeurs
musulmans voter pour jean luc mélenchon
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas d'autre offre
pour les présidentielles parce que le
barrage des 500 signatures est un
barrage extrême pour nous non ces
candidats à save en quelque sorte qu'ils
ne l'emporteront pas pourquoi se
présente il est bien en fait plus on se
présente plus on a de la visibilité
forcément et plus les idées donc des
petits partis vont pouvoir être prises
en fait par les autres partis politiques
et donc qu'ils vont être obligés de les
reprendre pour fédérer à des électeurs
quand je dis petit parti attention ce
n'est pas péjoratif c'est à dire qu'ils
font un score de 2 - 2 5% aux élections
et donc les petits partis c'est comme ça
qu'ils font partie qui font passer leurs
idées ils ont pas forcément besoin
d'être élu notre objectif à chaque
élection c'est de montrer complaisent
nos mesures plaisait et font mouche en
fait auprès des des citoyens de façon à
ce que au monde que cet électorat n'est
significatif et que tous les partis
politiques ont tout à s'intéresser aussi
aux mêmes idées en 2002 par exemple aux
élections présidentielles il neige aux
mains à louper donc deuxième tour pour
150000 bas dans c'est à dire zéro ce
dernier 6 % des lecteurs donc quand nous
nous représentons 2 % des lecteurs donc
vous voyez que c'est considérable et
vous en parlait il ya un autre enjeu
aussi pour ce scrutin des législatives à
venir simplement le fait d'avoir autant
de candidats ce n'est pas anodin a
autant de candidats qui qui ne partent
pas favoris est les citoyens ne sont pas
toujours au courant mais ça s'explique
par un enjeu financier très important
pour ces élections c'est l'occasion pour
les parties en fait de toucher des aides
financières de pouvoir satisfaire
finalement leur trésorerie pour le reste
de l'année et pour les cinq ans à venir
alors je vais m'expliquer en fait lors
des élections législatives chaque partie
peut obtenir une aide financière chaque
vous rapporte environ 1 euro 64 au parti
pendant cinq ans alors bien sûr tout on
ne touche pas à cette subvention il faut
remplir certains critères vous allez les
voir dans un instant obtenir à 1% des
voix dans 50 circonscriptions au moins
d'où la multiplication et grégory des
candidatures il faut également bien sûr
respecter la parité sous peine de voir
cette subvention est bien réduite le
nombre de candidats d'un même sexe d'un
même sexe ne doit pas excéder les 51% je
vais prendre l'exemple du parti
animalistes qu'on a donc interviewé il
présente douze candidats donc un
candidat dans chacune des
circonscriptions à des yvelines ils sont
un peu plus de 400 en france et bien les
candidats savent qu'ils vont faire des
petits scores ils nous l'ont dit mais
leur but c'est pas d'être élu à tout
prix c'est vraiment d'exister et donc
ils sont obligés de se présenter de
présenter à des candidats tout en
sachant qu'ils n'ont pas remporté cette
élection mais c'est pour la survie du
parti sur les cinq ans et pour eux c'est
ça le plus important c'est surtout une
ambition à long terme qui va nous
permettre d'engager des actions de faire
des meetings voilà sinon on est
effectivement limités parce que on a
par exemple déjà là on a on a engagé
toute notre trésorerie pour cette
élection au cours et donc pour finir
lorsqu'on voie à des alliances entre
petite formation politique ce n'est pas
pour espérer forcément avoir le plus de
voix et l'emporter mais bien sûr pour
toucher à dz peut-être pendant les cinq
ans à venir merci justin et vous parliez
justement du parti animalistes cette
année le mouvement politique présentera
plus de 400 candidats dans la france
entière dans les urines il y aura douze
candidats dans chacune des douze
circonscriptions du territoire et 10 de
plus qu'en 2010 est le reportage de
nickel et demi d'euros aujourd'hui
séance de tractage pour le parti
animalistes devant la gare de poissy
l'occasion pour les candidats civils loi
de faire connaître son mouvement
politique créé en 2016 et qui compte
plus de 400 candidats inscrits aux
élections législatives cette année dans
toute la france les partis politiques
classiques disons ne prennent pas
suffisamment au sérieux la cause animale
la question animale et qu'il faut
vraiment visibiliser un électorat pour
lequel la cause animale est vraiment
essentiel son terrain politique au total
douze candidats seront présents sur
l'ensemble des circonscriptions
yvelinoise dans son projet le parti veut
notamment interdire la chasse et la
chasse à courre on a aujourd'hui en fait
l'homme continue je dis bien l'homme est
pas l'humain je pense que ses hommes ont
perdu leur humanité donc ces hommes en
fait continuer à interpréter est né à
perpétrer des des traditions absolument
cruel dans quel monde vit-on
peut-on encore parler de deux personnes
civilisées lorsqu'on pratique encore des
choses aussi barbare une autre mesure
phare concerne les conditions dans les
abattoirs en réponse notamment images de
maltraitance animale diffusé en 2017 par
l'association l214 ans cet abattoir à
houdan comporte comme proposition
d'installer des caméras de
vidéosurveillance dans les abattoirs
choses qui avaient été promises mais qui
n'a malheureusement jamais été fait
c'est un parent par les pouvoirs publics
et on souhaite également entre autres
instauré l'obligation d'abattage avec
étourdissement en 2017 le parti
animalistes étaient présents dans deux
circonscriptions et avait recueilli un
peu plus de 1% des suffrages pendant les
élections législatives cette année les
candidats espèrent atteindre les 4% sur
l'ensemble du département
est à présent avec moi en plateau célia
kasongo bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78
on va faire avec vous un focus sur la 4e
circonscription des yvelines pour en
connaître les enjeux puisque jusqu au
1er tour de ces élections législatives
qui donc ont lieu ces élections
légistatives 12 et 19 juin le premier
tour c'est donc le 12 juin tv 60,18 vous
aide à y voir plus clair je vais voir
plus clair moi aussi ce soir avec vous
sur cette 4e circonscription quels sont
les déjà les communes qui composent
cette circonscription se dire elle se
situe dans le nord-est du département et
englobe plusieurs communes
carrières-sur-seine chatou croissy sur
seine où il loue sienne marly le roi ou
encore le port marly elle recense
presque senti mis leurs habitants alors
c'est une circonscription plutôt de
centre droit en 1988 c'est pierre
lequiller alors vice président du
conseil général
yvelines et maire de louveciennes les
élus pour le parti rue des f il sera
ensuite réélu jusqu'en 2017 sous
l'étiquette ump puis les républicains il
a décidé de ne pas se représenter en
2017 et c'est donc marie le bec du parti
de la république en marche qui le
succède à 61,39 % des suffrages face à
ghislain fournier alors maire de château
marie lebée qui est candidate à sa
propre succession oui en effet la
candidate sortante a la ferme intention
de retrouver son siège elle est
candidate cette fois sous la bannière
ensemble le parti de la majorité
présidentielle
elle compte approfondir le travail déjà
mises en place lors de son précédent
mandat notamment au niveau du
développement économique des écoles et
de la santé mary le bec par plutôt en
territoire conquis puisque emmanuel
macron est arrivé en tête de toutes les
circonscriptions de toutes les communes
de la circonscription à plus de 35%
alors qui sont les autres candidats
alors si une majorité de femmes au total
six femmes pour trois hommes parmi les
candidats on retrouve l'avocat écrivain
et chroniqueur charles consignes
personnage médiatique vous l'avez
sûrement entendu dans l'émission des
grandes gueules de rmc ou encore sur le
plateau d'on n'est pas couché il
s'engage maintenant politique sous
l'étiquette les républicains il avait
d'ailleurs déjà été un soutien actif un
de valérie pécresse qui semble qui pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
c'est donc le seul candidat qui semble
se démarquer même si les scores dans la
circonscription pour valérie pécresse
aux présidentielles ton plutôt autour de
la moyenne du département donc aux
alentours de 9% alors on retrouve aussi
des représentants de partis établis en
france comme sophie le landais pour le
rassemblement national ou encore céline
bourdon militante la france en soumises
pour la coalition une huppe ce la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale pour le reste on retrouve plutôt
des petits candidats comme bénédicte
rate iv pour le parti reconquête chloé
richard dembo pour le parti animalistes
ou encore franck morel pour la lutte
ouvrière merci célia et je le précise
premier tour de cette élection
législative gens n'étaient pas sûrs tout
à l'heure mais c'est bien le 12 juin et
le second tour éventuel second tour le
19 joueurs pour ce scrutin des
législatives merci pour toutes ces
précisions
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également un couple
devant le tribunal judiciaire de
versailles tous deux âgés de 33 ans ils
comparaissent pour avoir volé du
matériel informatique au technocentre de
guyancourt et tenter de le revendre sur
le bon coin et des vols qui ont eu lieu
entre le 1er mars 2021 et le 26 avril de
cette année pendant une période de
modernisation du réseau sur le site
renault montant total du préjudice plus
de 300000 euros les enquêteurs de la
sûreté urbaine d'elancourt ont été mis
sur la piste par une publication
suspectes sur le bon coin en remontant
l'adresse ip il tombe sur un couple
habitant en seine saint denis l'homme
travaille pour un prestataire du
technocentre renault placés en garde à
vue il a reconnu les vols et la
tentative de revente sa compagne elle a
également admis sa complicité et déferré
ils ont été placés sous contrôle
judiciaire et leur compte en banque
saisie et je vous en parlais dans les
titres des élèves de cm2 suivent des
ateliers de philosophie à l'école marcel
pagnol à coignières l'association sève
en partenariat avec l'éducation
nationale et la municipalité de
coignières dispense actuellement ses
cours à de nombreux bénéfices avec de
nombreux bénéfices en retour et on voit
tout de suite le reportage de céline
charles
[Musique]
imaginez
être sur une plage méditer pour
réfléchir pendant le temps de pratiquer
de la tension le cercle d'élèves de cm2
semble se calmer certains se prêtent au
jeu d'autres sourient aux ris mais une
chose est sûre lorsque la question
philosophique du jour est posée les
idées fusent aujourd'hui ce sera qu'est
ce qu'une vie réussie oui sa vie c'est
d'avoir fait la nation avoir rempli
monter the tings ou
parce qu'elles sont comprises c'est que
c'est un parent une news n avoir une
bonne famille qui ont confiance en nous
on essaie de les aider à réfléchir à
penser par eux-mêmes à approfondir leur
réflexion a interrogé peut-être remettre
en cause leurs certitudes penser par
soi-même ou encore développer son esprit
critique ces ateliers de philosophie
dispensés 12 fois dans l'année à bord de
plusieurs thèmes la violence le regard
de l'autre ou encore le bonheur témoin
vos thèmes préférés partie la différence
surtout pourquoi puisqu'on des délais
fléchira qu'est née qu'est la violence
larrieu légitimes et illégitimes de
tester donc ça nous a fait réfléchir on
estime que l'enfant tout petit déjà se
pose des questions même des questions
existentielles c'est quoi la mort c'est
quoi la vie pourquoi j'existe et se
posent des questions tout petit essai
pour les habitués justement à réfléchir
dès le plus jeune âge j'aime bien parler
en eaux calmes et de biens s'est quittés
ça évite les disputes des fois dans la
cour un peu hébété sanchez
on fait dire des iai appelle des
réponses sont à mourèze des ateliers
apprécié des enfants qui leur permettent
d'élaborer une vraie réflexion de
résister aux manipulations ou encore de
chasser les préjugés l'atelier
philosophique c'est aussi une forme de
prise de parole l'expression
l'apprentissage de la prise de paroles
l'apprentissage aussi du raisonnement ce
qui est important pour pour nos enfants
j'aime bien réfléchir et écouter les
réponses des autres par exemple tout à
l'heure j'ai appris la vraie définition
du mot re alors que moi je pensais
c'était juste à être content ça nous
apprend déjà les définitions ça nous
apprend à pas forcément faire tout ce
qu'on te dit ça nous apprend à réfléchir
et pas c'est pas parce que quelqu'un dit
quelque chose que nous on doit penser
pareil des ateliers qui sans avoir que
des retours positifs pour ces enfants
qui ne se prive pas de poursuivre les
débats le soir en famille ou dans la
cour de récréation si votre enfant est
plutôt aux passionnés par la musique le
chant ou la danse le dispositif shamshad
peut être intéressant ses classes à
horaires aménagés de la 6e à la 3e
permettent aux enfants de concilier que
les passions ce cursus est en place dans
trois écoles des yvelines et le collège
jules ferry à mantes la jolie fête cette
année le les 10 ans du dispositif matile
de franco
[Musique]
de la danse
du chant
et de la musique
au total une centaine d'enfants du
collège jules-ferry de mantes-la-jolie
bénéficient de classes à horaires
aménagés pour concilier leur passion
avec l'école j'ai commencé la chad en
sixième donc ça fait quatre ans mais
j'ai commencé la danse bien avant mais
c'était plutôt la continuité de la danse
ça apporte énormément parce que sans la
chamakh eu des cours techniques donc on
apprend vraiment que la technique tout
mais on a aussi beaucoup de théories qui
maintenant avec la cham donc on a des
ateliers chorégraphiques donc on apprend
sur la création comment bien créé une
chorégraphie avec on a beaucoup d'outils
ou on fait beaucoup de nouvelles choses
beaucoup plus de spectacles de concerts
donc on apprend beaucoup plus de choses
sur en général sur la danse sam afin de
découvrir beaucoup de plus de choses
parce que j'ai commencé vraiment dans le
classique que le classique j'ai
découvert les musiques actuelles avec ça
bon je suis rentré en dégroupage et je
vais commencer d'autres instruments ça
va paraître découvrir que je préférais
d'autres choses par exemple mais c'est
est ce que ces quatre années est très
sympathique grâce à ce cursus les
enfants suivent les mêmes cours que les
autres collégiens mais dispose d'une
après-midi banalisée pour se
perfectionner dans leur passion c'est la
dixième année pour le collège c'est
justement la raison pour laquelle on
fête les 10 ans cette année et donc on
voit que c'est un dispositif pérenne et
qui vraiment permet à de nombreux élèves
de 180 depuis les dix ans de pouvoir
accéder ensuite des parcours de réussite
dans des domaines artistiques mais de
s'épanouir et également sur des
pratiques artistiques en général le
collège jules-ferry travaille en
partenariat avec le conservatoire de
mantes la jolie pour profiter de ce
dispositif les familles doivent remplir
un dossier de candidature puis les
enfants passent une audition skie bien
en ce dispositif est de mettre les
enfants situation réside parce que ils
sont recrutés sur la motivation et c'est
on recrute pas les élèves sur le niveau
scolaire et donc ça permet vraiment de
à l'adolescence s'épanouir au cours de
sa scolarité au collège cette année le
conservatoire de mantes-la-jolie et le
collège jules-ferry fête les dix ans de
ce dispositif shamshad réunissant la
danse le chant et la musique les enfants
ont présenté un spectacle d'une heure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du sport pour refermer ce journal c'est
l'un des événements de l'année en france
le tournoi de roland garros se tient
jusqu'à dimanche porte d'auteuil à paris
plus de français à suivre c'est dommage
mais des affiches de rêve tout de même
un nadal djokovic pour ne citer que
cette affiche ce mardi soir en quart de
finale et c'est l'occasion pour nous
aussi de faire un état des lieux et du
tennis dans les yvelines avec mes
invités ils sont 200 plateaux lors
moreau bonsoir vice-président du comité
de tennis des yvelines également
jean-françois mettait bonsoir êtes le
secrétaire général de ce comité qui est
installé à feucherolles questions
directes pour commencer comment se porte
le tennis dans les yvelines après deux
années on le sait compliquée avec avec
la crise sanitaire tout à fait vain de
nous sommes très satisfaits de cette
reprise puisque aujourd'hui nous
atteignons des nous avons dépassé le
seuil des 40 mille licenciés donc une
progression de + 10 % par rapport à la
saison passée de date à date alors c'est
effectivement deux années très compliqué
avec le co vide mais on a tous nos au
club se sont mobilisés on a pu reprendre
notre activité assez rapidement puisque
le tennis est aussi un sport de plein
air et tous nos clubs s'y sont mis pour
avec l'application des des
gestes-barrières de tout ce qui est
contrôle sanitaire et on a pu redémarrer
l'activité assez rapidement et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
autre couvre nos adhérents et c'est un
vrai plaisir parce que finalement ils
tennis était parmi les pratiques on va
dire dans les premières à reprendre donc
c'est ça profité aussi pour la pratique
du tennis
des gens revenir revenir au tennis ce
que c'est un des premiers sports à
pouvoir prendre donc voilà on a vu des
anciens revenir et puis ils ont retrouvé
du plaisir à fouler les courts donc
voila nous à nous de garder ses
pratiquants qui sont venus en cas d'un
donc les perspectives sont plutôt bonnes
a pour les prochaines saisons pour la
saison à venir tout à fait mais juste
comme disait alors il faut maintenant
faire va continuer à travailler pour ça
que les gens raisonnent au club on a 150
157 clubs affiliés dans les yvelines
sont tous en progression et on s'en
félicite et je pense qu'on peut
remercier tous les dirigeants de nos
clubs pour les tous les efforts qu'ils
ont accomplie donc de très bons chiffres
pour la pratique du tennis dans les
yvelines on peut aussi compter bien sûr
sur des têtes d'affiché pour attirer un
peu plus de licenciés forcément arthur
rinderknecht c'est le nom dont on parle
le plus en ce moment qui a été formé au
tennis club des loges de saint germain
en laye qui est passé par feucherolles
qui était inconnu du grand public il
faut le dire il ya encore quelques mois
et le saint germanois est aujourd'hui
68e mondial est même monté jusqu'à une
48e place mondiale sur le classement atp
il a été appelé en équipe de france de
coupe davis même si les résultats
récents peuvent laisser sur une
déception et une élimination au premier
tour de roland garros et aussi au
deuxième tour de roland garros en double
avec benjamin bonzi quel regard vous
portez sur cette ascension qui a été
quand même fulgurante en 2021 et il a
été il faut le dire aussi plutôt
amoindri par une blessure au poignet ces
derniers ces dernières semaines quel
regard vous portez sur sur cette
fulgurante progression fait
effectivement arthur s'est blessé au
poignet et il avait passé deux tours à
l'open d'australie dont il était
vraiment de bon augure sa blessure mais
ça ne l'a contraint abandonnés et puis
partir un peu des terrains pendant
quelques quelques semaines alors
effectivement arthur un parcours
atypique puisque après être passé au
comité enfin ligue des yvelines à
l'époque il et il a fait un parcours un
peu universitaire aux états unis
qui lui a permis d'avoir une maturité
mais c'est vrai que c'est un parcours
atypique en dehors des filières fédéral
avec on le sait oui une arrivée tard sur
le circuit professionnel vous en parler
c'est la figure de proue du tennis des
yvelines aujourd'hui
peut-être pas mais souvent c'est un des
personnages qui compte maintenant sur le
niveau on a quand même quelques quelques
athlètes voilà prometteur on a aussi sur
des registres un peu plus on peut faire
un peu moins sportifs
sur un côté un peu plus sociétale on a
des joueurs en fauteuil qui se comporte
très bien d'un point de vue y compris
internationale
voilà avec une aura une aura
particulière sur des thématiques de
société donc
voilà arthur est un parcours atypique
mais il est parmi un groupe qui fait
parler d'eux aujourd'hui donc chez les
femmes bien que et paquet aussi
notamment 101e mondiale qui a fait un
tour un premier tour de roland garros
intéressant il ya eu quand même un set
gagné face
face à blake finalement une élimination
au premier tour mais c'est quand même
une belle entrée en matière pour créer
paquet commente pas vraiment c'est
effectivement alors pour rebondir sur ce
que disait alors effectivement on a
d'autres aussi jeune pépite qui arrive
derrière comme antoine bibeau d'antoine
bibeau norton ghibaudo qui vient
malheureusement que perdre aussi hier à
roland garros le tournoi juniors mais
qui est en pleine progression et qui
continue sa progression d'ailleurs on
forme aussi des plus jeunes on à théo
supiot qui a 13 ans gars qui est très
prometteur qui est du niveau national
la petite colline adad hannah hook à 12
ans aussi très prometteur et puis on a
quatre petites filles de 2,9 en a qui
viennent d'avoir un titre de championne
de france entre guillemets puisque à 9
ans il joue par équipe mais qui sont
vraiment
notre nos espoirs pour les années à
venir et puis on a aussi le pôle le pôle
tes ne pas rater nice conforme au comité
au vue des jo de paris 2024 avec de
paris 2004 avec un comité des yvelines
kg et centres d'entraînement c'est ça
pour pour c'est vieillot voilà donc oui
effectivement on a été labellisé centre
d'entraînement donc on va pouvoir
recevoir les délégations quand il le
demanderont mais je parlais du para
tennis effectivement l'un d'eux figure
de proue avec pauline dérouler dans
l'une des roulettes qui vise
effectivement une médaille aux jo paris
2024 en fauteuil quelle histoire
une histoire vraiment aussi traître est
bouleversante et qui témoigne énormément
sur sur cet handicap il ya d'ailleurs un
cours pauline déroulé d'un qui a été
inauguré il me semble dans le nord des
yvelines du côté drôle d'oiseau on avait
assisté on avait pu assister à cette
inauguration
on a parlé aussi avec vous de deux
événements à venir alors y en a un qui
concerne justement le tennis en fauteuil
puisque c'est le premier tournoi
international de tennis fauteuil qui
aura lieu à feucherolles la discipline
on l'a dit à une ambassadrice dans les
yvelines mais même au niveau français
c'est pauline des roulettes enfin un
tournoi qui est qui en novembre c'est
bien ça
l'or va être la directrice des
tournelles grands honneurs la directrice
du tournoi en fait on s'est un petit peu
échauffés avec un tournoi national en
fauteuil cette année qui a réuni un
tableau de 16 joueurs et joueuses donc
là on passe au niveau supérieur avec
l'ambition de faire aussi bien voire
mieux sur cette édition internationale
donc c'est une grande fierté pour nous
parce qu'il ya très peu de tournois
organisés de ce type en ile de france
donc donc voilà c'est un beau projet d'
équipe aussi et puis toutes les tous les
athlètes de cette discipline sont son
moteur aussi dans ce type de projet sert
qu'on n'hésite pas à des concepts
concertée ensemble pour organiser tout
ça voilà parce qu'il ya un cahier des
charges quand même bien bien particulier
donc c'est une belle aventure qui
continue avec avec ce tournoi sans
oublier évidemment les autres événements
internationaux comme des winter cup qui
arrivera en tête petite avance vraiment
vous me tendez la perche pour terminer
nous reste un peu plus d'une minute pour
terminer sur la winter cup qui est la
coupe d'europe dès 12 ans filles à une
deuxième édition ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle qui va arriver en janvier 2023
dans les yvelines tout à fait puisque
les deux dernières années
malheureusement tennis europe a été
obligé d'annuler ces compétitions pour
les problèmes de transport puis de crise
sanitaire on se réjouit de pouvoir enfin
faire notre deuxième édition
donc c'est la conseille la fed cup pour
les l'équivalent effectué pour les
jeunes filles de 12 ans et léna
française donc il y aura il ya quatre
pays qui organisent une phase
qualificative dont la france dont
faustroll et on aura donc l'équipe de
france avec sept autres nations à
feucherolles durant ce long week end ça
sera le dernier week-end de janvier donc
de vos rendez-vous on les rappelle à ce
tournoi international de tennis fauteuil
qui aura lieu en novembre dans les
yvelines est également la deuxième
édition de la winter cup ans en janvier
2023 on rappelle aussi on l'a dit tout à
l'heure avec le comité des yvelines sera
centre d'entraînement pour les jo de
paris 2024 et donc vous espérez vous
pouvez en tout cas recevoir des
délégations en vue de cet événement
mondial qui va arriver pour la france
merci en tout cas d'être venu parler de
cette actualité du tennis dans les
yvelines avec nous lors moreau
vice-président du comité de tennis des
yvelines est également jean-françois
et secrétaire général de ce
comité qui est installé à feucherolles
on retrouve bien sûr toutes les
informations sur le site internet qui
s'est affichée au cours de cet entretien
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant vous
retrouverez célia gars de 100 go aux
commandes du 7-8 culture belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]